who's ever in Carmichael what's message
do you have for the people your time was
important Nina got me drunk but Nina
felt great that's a good husband to do
here we're going to stop the video right
there
update last night we were supposed to go
dancing but Nina passed out at like
eight o'clock so we started watching a
movie and she's reading the book and she
passed said she woke up briefly at 11 or
something I said okay you ready to go
dancing uh-huh as she passed that again
so Evan was basically by myself last
night and we decided we'd sleep in this
is not a lot to do in st. Croix and so
we're going to go get some breakfast
although it's really late what time is
like hell we got off the boat we're
usually up and off the boat it's just
fascinating it's 10 you're still on the
boat but Nina felt great because she
slept well and she's really happy and
that's worth it I think okay good so
breakfast and then get off the book so
looks like we're the only cruise ship in
town which is strange every other ports
had multiple ships going to be a sleepy
day probably
maybe Nina needs another nap nap on the
beach or five hours yeah we'll see we'll
see we're gonna go explore
so we're on one of the main streets here
in st. Croix King Street and it's
totally empty because they're getting
ready for a parade it's 1130 right now
and we asked what time to start is it
supposed to be kind of clock I don't
think I could handle this island time
thing I hate wasting time and helping
being hours late no patients name needs
it right now I'm training Alex who's the
new guy who are hired to help me with
China that salsa his punctuality isn't
always break which bothers me because
it's also my time right it's not just
his time it's my time you got to show up
to be on time or early so I'm not
wasting my time with you the next time
that needs more than five minutes late
I'm locking the door walk in the door
i'm not letting them in that's it Alex
keeping warrants if you're watching this
you can warrant if you're late I'm
locking the door just kind of make it a
priority right like when you go to an
airport you know the airplanes gonna
leave at a certain time or yeah they're
gonna wait for you why do we allow
people to be late for us your time is
important lock people out if they're
late that's it new plan you're late for
meeting with me you're locked out lock
the people out of your lives if they
disrespect your time hey one of them
with her started baby I know I bent the
rule for her she kept me waiting for
like out an hour the first time yeah
it's just because you're cute that's all
nano want some coconut juice
what's the message do you have for the
people can we go to the most famous café
restaurant on the island Polly's grab
the drink
so that was good to relax that's the
fastest Wi-Fi we've had I know it's like
half decent normal actual Wi-Fi the
parade might be just standing Oh homie
to have then I was like 130
so the freight stop oh just some unknown
reason so we're going to go back to the
boat okay Nina's hungry I'm full and so
we're going to eat and I'm going to go
workout because when you have a huge
meal use this would work out right on
that's what they say
and I really just keeping Nina company
and that's a good husband too okay we're
off the workout name is still a little
bit better this time I'm prepared I got
my music I got my games I got things to
keep me distracted while i'm working at
and we're gonna go Nina also was think
about doing a 30 day fitness challenge
weight loss weight loss challenge was to
get back because it been eating too much
oh my god I don't know how much meeting
so we'll see we'll film it will see you
guys like that idea leave it in the
comments and we'll see
let's do legs are jello didn't work out
for an hour you know rush me out there
wasn't able do a proper warm down cool
down but it's okay uh what what sex
we're gonna shower shower and then
dinner instead of time game is all
dressed up I'm all done for both dressed
up I'm gonna go eat okay last dinner on
the cruise ship are you feeling what
message do you want to share cuz i
worked out 30 day challenge what's your
goal 113
how much of a difference is that because
we'll see good morning just got rudely
woken up but we do have to get skype guy
wasn't a slam on the door but we do have
to get up in there 15 minutes until
breakfast closer so it was actually not
that bad it's 815 what happened last
night we went back to the cabin Nina got
me drunk we watched the last airbender I
like that movie that's good you should
know the acting was really bad but I
liked it I liked the story and then I
missed my window to sleep went to bed at
four in the morning so don't have a lot
of sleep not very conscious yet we're
going to get breakfast pack up and get
going to San one last breakfast on the
cruise ship all right we're getting up
the boat we didn't post much this
morning mostly one because we're too
tired
and zonked out and then we're rushing to
pack up and leave evan is the family
donkey carrying everything super excited
though that I didn't have to use my big
camera brought it along with me but I
filmed all of the vlog kind of videos on
my hero 4 silver and all of the regular
videos the interests of the top tens all
that stuff we're just filmed on Nina's
phone and 11 plus 11 plus 2 so we're
going to hit the old san juan have some
fun so we're sending outside by regina
and what these guys are known for our
having a place we've to top off your
bags and i forgot much at the pay is
comfy but play store basically tours to
leave the bags to the day so you can go
enjoy sign one and then come back and
pick up pretty cool thing to do with the
rest and a good way to drive people into
your
I feel lighter okay so they just
basically the guy their works for tips
and it brings people into the restaurant
we are on the hunt for our first time in
a week we've asked for people and
everybody tells us different directions
but Nina found somebody with a Starbucks
cup and is that they go this way so r on
our way now has that friend Trevor comes
in every city every time I go away we
have to find something to tell me
all right when we relax they're an hour
almost 45 minutes hey oh wait okay
and that's awesome when I go to score we
got an hour and a half then gotta catch
a cab to the airport so we turn on the
first screen annina already has done
some shopping promise goodbye cigar oh
wow we're going to smoke that on the way
home do you want this now
she got for her boss I had to stand
outside the store because the smell was
so bad taste in smoke I'm sneaking up on
Nina we're at marshalls she has a cart I
mean she found something what did you
find friend it's just what it feels nice
is that how you make a decision on the
brush really so far we've gone to two
stars and Lena is shopping up a storm
here we got stopped on the street by
Puerto Rican he said who's Evan
Carmichael spreading some believe to
Puerto Rico Nina's hungry vomit at the
cafe he'll photo which did well on
tripadvisor gonna grab some food and
then head off huh alright we got our
bags
heading to the airport
ok
I come okay we made it hi this is a very
low energy update what are we doing we
just waiting for a flight excited to go
home I miss home I miss home it's going
to be snowing and cold we were warned
but I'm like being away for too long too
much good stuff is happening back
we're in business possible
delays of your work but it's good they
were first times just kick the back
straight there we go okay welcome home
thank you for joining us on a vacation
if they were home all right let us know
what you think in the comments you guys
see believe